i feel much more seen when i'm referred
to as they
emiquoren covers the august issue of
vogue where the 26 year old actor who
rose to fame portraying a young princess
diana in netflix's the crown discusses
quietly coming out as queer and
non-binary after playing a uniquely
feminine role
all i want is to be loved
it's all any of us want from you in
april of last year corrin first
self-identified to the public as a
member of the lgbtq plus community and
opening up to the magazine about their
fluidity corin says
in my mind gender just isn't something
that feels fixed and i don't know if it
ever will be there might always be some
fluidity there for me
sharing they are in awe of the younger
generation's openness the golden globe
winner adds
the next generation is so much more
chill they are finding a way to express
themselves which is less binary in a
very organic way and corrin noticed this
firsthand with their younger brother
after the actor began dating women
telling vogue i started dating a girl
and told my mom and then my little
brother dm'd me saying hey i wanted to
say welcome because i've been bi for
ages
you can sense the waves
you know how strong they are
cory will next appear alongside harry
styles and the romantic drama my
policeman and later in the netflix
adaptation of lady chatterley's lover
but the actor shares that enacting
femininity on screen isn't always
comfortable stating i remember
struggling with having to wear bras in
chatterley and as marion but it's quite
difficult because i'm not emma right i'm
an actor and i have a job to do